spike lee uh filmmaker particularly of
the black power variety
uh spike lee wearing a 1619 hat just
lamented at a recent conference
black people are being hunted down by
the police since you brought up do the
right thing
a couple weeks ago was the 32nd
anniversary of the film that film came
out in 1989
i wrote it in 1988
when you see
brother eric garner
when you see king george floyd
lynched
i think of radio rahim
and you would think in hope that
30 some [ __ ] years later
the black people stop
being hunted down like the animals black
people are not hunted down like animals
none of the data show that whatsoever
it's not
not even close the idea that black
people are being hunted down by police
is an absolute farce
it just doesn't happen the idea that
george floyd is a king
is also suspect it's just we're just
living in this
bizarre narrative that is so
disconnected from reality spike lee
might genuinely believe these things
he's wrong he's hallucinating he's
imagining these things
but that that is the power of speech in
a republic you know
blm blm of utah didn't know there was a
blm of utah
utah not the blackest state in america
but okay there's a blm of utah
just came out and said that the american
flag is a symbol
of hatred you know
you know i hate to say i told you so but
i said this this is this is the power of
speech in the power of standards we now
have a new
national it's the black national anthem
we now have a new international
independence day it's called juneteenth
it's
right there in the title of the bill we
now have a new
origin story of our country it's not
1776 or 1620 it's 16 19. we now have a
new sense of ourselves it's not a good
country it's an evil country it's a
racist country
we're going to have a new flag we
already do sort of have a new flag
is the star spangled banner is a symbol
of hatred this is the this is the power
of speech we've got to get a handle
on speech and on our narrative or else
we're gonna have a completely different
country if we don't already
hey yo you you gotta subscribe you gotta
like
you to comment you got to engage i want
your engagement you can watch this whole
episode by the way
which is called donald trump versus
hipster rasputin you can catch it here
you can catch it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher
myspace xanga all over the place you can
also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling ones
number one national bestseller thanks to
wonderful readers
like you let me know what you think
about it see you next time
[Music]
you